what i want to do in this video is think
a little bit about what happens to some
type of projectile maybe a ball a ball
or a rock if i were to throw it up
straight up into the air so to do that
and what i want to do is i want to plot
its distance relative to time so there's
a few things that i'm going to tell you
about my throwing of the rock in the air
will have an initial velocity i'll have
an initial velocity of
19.6 meters per second and i picked this
initial velocity because it will make
the map a little bit a little bit easier
and we also know the acceleration near
the surface of the earth we know that
the force of gravity near the surface of
the earth is is the mass of that object
times let me write this down
the force of gravity
the force of gravity uh on an object
near the surface of the earth is going
to be the mass of the object times
little g
times gravity on earth this is 9.8
meters meter meters per second squared
now if you want the acceleration
on earth you just divide force divided
by mass right because we have
where force is equal to mass times
acceleration if you want acceleration
divide both sides by mass so you get
force
over mass so let's just divide this by
mass or let me divide both sides of this
by mass
if you divide both sides of this by mass
on this on the left hand side you get
acceleration and on the right hand side
right over here you get the same
quantity g and the whole reason why i
did this is when we look at the little g
it really comes from the universal law
of gravitation and you can really view
it as the
as as measuring the field strength of
the gravitational field strength near
the surface of the earth and then that
helps us figure out when you multiply it
by mass the force then you'll use f
equals m a newton's second law to come
up with g again which is actually the
acceleration and accelerate and it's
accelerating you towards the center of
the earth the other thing i want to make
clear and you might have already thought
about this is when you talk about
gravity the force of gravity generally
you're saying look the force of gravity
is equal to big g which is different
than the little g
times the product of the masses of the
two things times the square of the
distance between the two objects
and so you might be saying wait
clearly clearly the force of gravity is
dependent on the distance and so if i
were to throw something up into the air
won't the distance change and you would
be right that is technically right but
the reality is is that when you throw
something up in the air that change in
distance is so small relative to the
distance between that object and the
center of the earth that to make the
math simple when we're at the when we're
at or near the surface of the earth
including in our atmosphere we can
assume it is constant
we can assume it is constant remember
that little g right over there is really
all of these terms combined if we assume
that mass 1 is the cent is the earth or
mass of the earth
and r right here is the distance really
the radius of the earth from the surface
of the earth to the center of earth
radius
radius of earth so you'd be correct in
thinking that it actually changes a
little bit the force of gravity changes
a little bit but for the sake of
throwing things up in our atmosphere and
all of that we can assume that it is
constant and if you were to calculate it
it is
9.8 meters per second squared and i've
rounded here to the nearest tenth
and i want to be clear these are vector
quantities and in this when we start
throwing stuff up in the air the
convention is is that up
if something is moving up it is we'll
give it a positive value and if
something is moving down we give it a
negative value
well
gravity would be excel
for an object that's in free fall
gravity would be accelerating it
downwards or the force of gravity is
downwards so little g right over here if
we want to give its direction is
negative
is negative 9.8 meters per second
squared so we have the acceleration due
to gravity so the acceleration due to
gravity is going to be negative
9.8
meters
per second squared and i want to plot
distance relative to time so let's think
about
let's think about how we can set up a
formula how we can derive a formula that
if we input time as a dependent variable
we can get distance and we could we can
assume these values right over here
well we know
or even more important i want to plot
displacement versus time because that
will actually be more interesting in
this problem
so we know that displacement we know
that displacement is the same thing as
average velocity
average velocity times times change in
time
so right now we have something in terms
of
time distance and average velocity but
not in terms of initial velocity and
acceleration right over here but we know
that average velocity we know that
average velocity is the same thing as
initial velocity
plus final velocity over two if we
assume constant acceleration so we can
we can do this assuming
assuming
constant acceleration and once again
and once again when we're dealing we're
not too far from the surface of the
earth we can make that a assumption
assuming
we have a constant acceleration
but this right here once again we don't
have what our final velocity is so we
need to think about this a little bit
more but we can express our final
velocity in terms of our initial
velocity and time
so this expression right here so we're
just dealing with this part of the
average velocity so we can rewrite this
expression as the initial velocity plus
something over 2 and what is final
velocity well the final velocity i'll do
it in that same yellow color the final
velocity is going to be your initial
velocity plus your
plus your acceleration plus your
acceleration times change in time
right if you're starting at 10 meters
per second and you accelerate at 1
meters per second squared then after a
second you'll be going one meter per
second faster than that so this right
here this right here is your
is your final velocity let me make sure
that these are all vector quantities
so all of these things over here are
vector quantities i sometimes might
forget that forgive me i hope hopefully
by now it's pretty ingrained in you that
these are all vector quantities that the
direction matters and let's see if how
we can simplify this
well these two terms remember we're just
dealing with this average velocity term
right over here these two terms these
two if you combine them become 2vi
times my initial velocity and then
divided by this 2
plus all of this business divided by
this 2
plus my acceleration times change in
time
divided by 2. so all of this was another
way to write average velocity and the
whole reason why i did this is because
we don't have final velocity here but we
have acceleration and we're going to use
change in time as our independent
variable and so we also have to still
multiply this by this green change in
time right over here
by this green change in time and all of
this was what displacement is going to
be this is displacement and let's see we
can multiply the change in time times
all of this business and actually these
twos cancel out
and we get i'll continue it over here so
i can use all of the real estate we get
that displacement displacement is equal
to
the initial velocity
is equal to initial velocity times
change in time
times change in i'm doing that same
color times change in time
and a lot of times in a lot of physics
books or traditional physics classes
they'll just write time there but it's
really change in time
and you know it's not super wrong if
there's just a t here but change in time
is is a little bit more accurate and
then plus
plus
you have one half that's the same thing
as dividing by two
plus one half
times the acceleration times the
acceleration
times we have a delta t times delta t
change in time times change in time this
triangle just means change in so change
in time times change in time is just
change in time squared
change in time squared and in some
classes you will sometimes see this
written as you know maybe d is equal to
vi times t plus one half a t squared
same exact thing they're just using d as
the variable for displacement and
they're using t instead of delta t these
are the same things but the one thing i
want you to realize in this video is
that this is just a very this is a very
straightforward thing to derive you
really
maybe if you're under time pressure you
might want to just make sure that you
know just be able to whip this out but
the important thing so that you remember
how to do this when you're 30 years old
or 40 years old or 50 years old or when
you're an engineer you're trying to send
a rocket into space and you don't have a
physics book to look up is it just comes
from the simple displacement is equal to
average velocity times change in time
and we assume constant acceleration and
then you can kind of just derive the
rest of this now i'm going to leave you
there in this video we're going to we're
going to leave off let me erase this
part right over here
i'm going to leave it right over here in
the next video we're going to use this
formula we just derived we're going to
use this to actually plot
to plot the displacement versus time
because that's interesting then we're
going to be thinking about what happens
to the velocity and the acceleration as
we move as as as we move further and
further ahead in time